foreign
debate friends
all right we're here Jared you have to
you have to survey so there people we're
back because uh we apparently made it
palatable for the first few few people
first debate we're glad to be here with
you we'll uh give a little breakdown
what we expect before the debate really
quickly uh first drink responsibly but
our official drinking game rules are up
here we've got them right here let me
show you the rules that are on my screen
okay Jared bring them up
you must drink anytime Trump says
frankly tremendous trust me honestly
truthfully excuse me let me tell you or
if he mentions China Mexico or
interrupts every time you take a drink
that could be a sip
you play by your rules you must take a
sip of your beverage every time Hillary
Clinton refers to him as Donald as
opposed to Mr Trump anytime she coughs
laughs inaudibly in a little silent sort
of inner soul deafening cackle it's
terrible plays a sexist card mentions
hot sauce uh commits our BF or the
moderator interrupts on her behalf and
by the way a warning here this is a
strong R because we have to actually
quote the presidential candidates but
you never thought we'd have to say that
so strong are got the kids out right now
five four three and if the phrase grab
them by the ever makes an
appearance induce alcohol poisoning yep
yep you will hear hey
every time one of these acts is
committed oh there's a point
at which point drink up grab them by the
that's what you do so this happens
we want to what do I expect first from
the debates tonight uh Jared what do you
expect I expect this is a Do or Die for
Donald Trump it is one of two trumps
could either appear he'll be entirely
subdued because he's terrified after the
worst week in a presidential uh
campaign I guess if you call it that at
this point or he just comes out scorched
Earth all guns blazing Kamikaze brings
up Bill what do you think we'll see I I
honestly I just have no idea I'm hoping
for the letter I'm hoping he because I
think it's only his only chance of
turning this weekend around yeah is to
go strong after Bill and we haven't seen
we've seen him do it a little bit in
tweets this last couple days
it feels the balls to do in person we
will find out I think I think we'll see
more of the same from Hillary I don't
think that she needs she doesn't need to
change that much no oh speaking of the
rapist oh there we go rapist lots of
rape here on the stage uh so let me
address the controversy here this week
um it shouldn't come as any surprise to
anyone who's read Donald Trump's book
but
let me say this policy wise I will
probably line up with Donald Trump more
than Hillary Clinton if you look at the
platforms as far as people I think it is
really hard at this point to say that
either of them are anything more than a
horrible human being grabbing by the
I don't think Donald Trump or
Hillary Clinton are good people I think
both of them are bad people okay let me
just characterize I think they're both
really bad people now people are talking
about the controversy and one thing they
go oh so he used some bad language this
is how guys talk Pine women's back
um no
no it's not I don't I know uh Jared now
we it's one thing to swap sex stories
it's one thing to make some crude jokes
but to talk about violating a married
woman
if it's your wife and you were saying I
tried to her
grab him by the if you're a
husband and you're okay with someone
saying that about your wife or your
daughter I don't have any respect for
you I don't have any respect for that
woman who would be okay being treated
that way let's be real here because a
lot of people out there want to
whitewash what Donald Trump has said and
oh you know no I tried to her grab
her by the
let's just be real about it talking
about a married woman I will tell you
this I had a friend who I did grappling
with Jiu Jitsu with and I found out he
was talking one time about how he slept
with his uh best friend's girlfriend and
he was no longer my friend because we
want to talk about loyalty trust well
listen the three by the way Donald Trump
was married Melania was pregnant at this
point and I will tell you this the
judges who are overseeing rape cases I
think there's going to be a hearing
December 16th this is admissible
and what they said is exactly what
Donald Trump claimed he did they said he
Force forced himself upon them and
kissed them against their will without
their consent and tried to grope them
does it mean that it's true no but you
know what I didn't like it when Bill
Clinton did it it wasn't acceptable with
uh with with Juanita Broderick it wasn't
acceptable with Paula Jones so if you
want to say and I understand this Donald
Trump is better than Hillary Clinton and
they're both bad and I have to vote for
him I can respect that but don't try and
do the mental gymnastics and act as
though this is anything other than an
absolute scumbag who you would not
invite to your dinner party
and by the way this whole he's he's
losing in a landslide in the polls right
now okay and the one thing people point
out Jared we've talked about this people
say well look at his rallies look at his
rallies look at the look at the Drudge
Report poll let me show you this tweet
from Mitt Romney condemning Donald
Trump's actions 105 000 likes 54 000
retweets
tweet from Hillary Clinton no enthusiasm
condemning Donald Trump 88 000 likes 47
000 retweets Donald Trump lashing out
fighting back
44 000 likes 16 000 retweets that's less
than a quarter that's less than a fifth
of Romney's interactions so if we're
only gonna make the barometer popular
opinion guess what you're losing that
one too and you're not doing someone any
favors by absolving them of this here's
the I I want to see people expect more
from their candidates that's what I want
I don't think you're doing any of these
people any favors by letting them off
the hook for any of it so if you're
tuning in for cheerleading oh no I just
want to see everyone called on their BS
tonight and uh of course we're going to
have a few laughs but at this point it's
a it's a show it's an entertainment show
I don't have a huge vested interest I
really don't and I think a lot of people
out there feel that way I know my mom
who would have voted for Trump won't now
I know my dad who thought it was a
lesser of two evils probably won't now I
know my wife won't now
so these are people who are saying all
right I'm not a huge fan but I have to
to stop Hillary I know many people who
this has been a turning point for them
not saying it's the Turning Point what
do you think Jared I know we have to go
to the debates because it's starting
here
you know I think I people have followed
me on Twitter have probably felt
gathered some of my thoughts it's just I
don't know how it's just at what point
at some point it becomes indefensible
even for the people closest buying you
know people like Mike Pence who
just even Melania had to call him out on
how offensive this thing was his words
were she was forced to come out and say
that's pretty bad and by the way if
you're hanging there's some guys who
talk about and
grabbed by the person other men's wives
you're hanging around bad people
it's not that someone said the word
I don't know if that's not that
has nothing to do with it yeah it's not
even that someone would have made a rape
joke this is someone advising someone
else on how to sexually accost and no
matter how long ago no matter how long
10 years ago 20 years ago whatever you
want to do
he was saying something about he was he
was younger and immature back then
you're 59 years old back then Don
59 years old
at what point do this does your
character take a take a take a right
turn for the better I I know I I mean
that's right that's where I'm coming
from I just I'm just I just I just I
want to stop with the facade that's what
I want to stop with the okay
and I can say that because our potential
president imagine that I have to violate
the FCC just to quote the possible
president that's all I want I want to
stop with the
let's not act like all guys are cheating
on their wives and saying grab them by
the person let's not act like all women
are sleeping with men like Bill Clinton
who are also rapists let's and let's not
act like all public servants are this
bad they aren't there were some other
choices who were decent people these are
not among them that's what I think these
are not decent human beings these are
bad representatives of the human race
let alone the United States okay if you
don't like that that's fine uh do I hope
at this point since we have someone who
is married to and has defended a serial
rapist and somebody who is likely
asexual assault assailant do I think
Donald Trump is probably better than
Hillary Clinton policy wise probably
probably that's kind of where I am but
don't mistake that as rooting for the
home team at this point also I think
it's going to be an Andrew Breitbart the
name not the trademark I think it's
going to be an Andrew situation I think
the worst is yet to come I think they've
got more they're going to drip out from
Donald Trump with interviews that's what
I think I think you're going to make him
apologize for this say it was an
isolated incident and I wouldn't be
surprised if they bring out something
more recent
go back and listen to the podcast how
often did I say the clintons they're
gonna they're the master of the October
surprise I mean you can go back over a
year what I've been talking about that
whoever runs against them needs to be
ready to deal with a bombshell in
October and I don't think I think it's
gonna worse it's gonna get worse I think
it's going to get worse and you know and
here's the deal too I hate feminists
because I love women because I love
because I think my I think my wife is
better than that I think women are
smarter than that I don't hate feminists
because I hate women
and I think people who say we all talk
about women like this behind their back
no listen objectifying women talking
about their looks sure of course talking
about grabbing by the person with a
married woman no that's not typical guy
talk okay I'm sorry it's not
um and uh I'm just tired of people doing
the mental loop-de-loops to try and
justify all this whether they're
democrat or republican expect more from
these people they need to earn your vote
remember that they're supposed to earn
your vote stop cheerleading stop getting
on the train cult wagon whoever it is my
God this is just a shameful display uh I
tell you it's going to be a shameful
display the beverages consumed tonight
with this drinking game we up the Annie
with a drinking game uh let us know what
you're drinking and uh we're not only
going to stream the debate we're going
to live stream The Young Turks live
stream in the debates at some point here
yep so it was like Inception a stream
within a stream it is it's trippy and
people are saying tell not gay Jared to
stop taking little wimpy sips
what you did last time
you see the thing is you can say things
if you get you know Drinker too far and
things go really weird technically
someone says don't have the best service
but only your feed freezes
what is that it's freezing it's freezing
not get here are we sure this is working
a lot of people are saying they're
having problems with the stream let me
check here at ar15.com
yep okay home my wife is saying
all right some people saying uh I'm at
work right now we'll watch no it seems
to be working someone was shocked that I
said yeah I know but listen
it's it's it's it's working now okay
it's working now for my wife even though
I said stop distracting me she cannot
listen
it is not when the wife keeps speaking
up out of term that's where you have to
grab them by the that's just what
you have to do it's not advice I don't
know how you do that are you fish
hooking them how do you how do you grab
an absence grabbing by the it's
like it's like
a bar of soap
it's impossible to do oh he's cruel
grabbing by the grabbing by the
hot sauce
refreshing I want anytime Hillary
Clinton says this tonight that's us
consume your entire beverage
beverages
beverage beverage
uh anyway hopefully it's entertaining I
just think it's at this point where I'm
gonna sit back and enjoy the show oh my
God who is that who is that ladies and
gentlemen the Republican nominee for
president all right here we go Donald J
Trump and the Democratic nominee for
president Hillary Clinton
get off the internet
is it working the Stream
they list him it's he lists himself at
six three I don't know about that um
thank you very much for being here we're
going to begin with a question from one
of the members in our town hall uh each
of you will have two minutes to respond
to this question secretary Clinton you
won the coin toss so you'll go first our
first question comes from Patrice Brock
Patrice
thank you and good evening
the last presidential debate could have
been no
mature audiences our TV parental
guidelines knowing the Educators to sign
viewing the presidential debates as
students homework do you feel you're
remodeling appropriate and positive
behavior for today's youth
[Music]
because I've heard from lots of teachers
and parents about some of their concerns
about some of the things that are being
said and not only about your husband
raping them in this campaign uh and I
think it is very important for us to
make clear to a smoking jacket that our
country really
because we're good and we are going to
respect one another lift each other up
we are going to be looking for ways to
celebrate our diversity
and we are going to try to reach out to
every boy and girl as well as every
adult uh to treaties don't forget the
treaties
and your guess is as good as mine
category that's why the slogan of my
campaign is stronger together because I
think if we work together
overcome the divisiveness that sometimes
sets Americans against one another and
instead we make some big goals and I've
set forth some big goals getting the
economy to work for everyone not just
those at the top making sure that that's
what she quotes when she's like just
passing out and being dragged by her her
Secret Service
he's carrying out like Xerxes try to
achieve them there's nothing in my
opinion that America can't do so that's
why I hope that we will come together in
this campaign obviously I'm hoping to
earn your vote I'm hoping to be a
elected in November and I can promise
you I will work with every American I
want to be the president for all
Americans regardless of your political
beliefs all she does is trash
Republicans and Bernie voters I want us
to heal our country and bring it
together who's the one who's been
causing the damage that you need to heal
to get the future that our children and
our grandchildren deserve secretary
Clinton thank you Mr Trump you have two
minutes well I actually agree with that
I agree with
everything she said he looks like Pepe
there he does this campaign because I
was so tired
resting face oh
this is a great country this is what
does it sound and sound is coming to
know the people country over the last
year and a half that I've been getting
my crap together that is total arresting
basic face someone get her a
pumpkin spice latte myself but I guess I
have been a politician and my whole
concept was to make America great again
when I watch the deals being made when I
watch what's happening with
some horrible things like Obamacare
where your health insurance and Health
Care is going up by numbers that are
astronomical 68 59
71 percent
well we're giving back 150 billion
dollars to a terrorist State what if
you're just thinking about all those
numbers on the spot we've made them a
strong country from really a very weak
country just three years ago someone's
saying our voices are too loud we're
covering up the sound of a stream
country has we have such tremendous
potential whether it's in business and
trade where we're doing so badly last
year we had an almost 800 billion dollar
trade deficit in other words trading
with other countries we had an 800
billion dollar deficit it's hard so he's
been advised to focus on these deals
we're going to make great trade deals
we're going to have a strong border
we're going to bring back Law and Order
just today
policeman was shot two we're gonna
grabbed by the and this is
happening on a weekly basis we have to
bring back respect to law enforcement at
the same time we have to take care of
people in all sides we need Justice
but I want to do things that haven't
been done including fixing and grabbing
by the person for the African-American
citizens that are so great and for the
Latinos Hispanics and I look forward to
doing it's called make America great
again thank you Mr Trump the question
from Patrice was about are you both
modeling positive and appropriate
behaviors for today's news
a lot of questions online Mr Trump about
the tape that was released on Friday as
you can imagine you called what you said
locker room banter you describe kissing
women without consent grabbing their
generals that is sexual assault you brag
that you have sexually assaulted women
I don't think you understood what was
said this was locker room talk uh I'm
not proud of it I apologize to my family
I apologize to the American people never
asked for forgiveness before I know this
is locker room we have a world locker
room door devices chopping off heads
married women and frankly
and horrible horrible sights all over
where you have so many bad things
happening this is like medieval times we
haven't seen anything like this the
Carnage all over the world
and they look and they see can you
imagine the people
doing so well against us with Isis and
they like it that's like stamina what's
going on yes I'm very embarrassed by it
I hate it but it's locker room talk and
it's one of those things I will knock
the hell out of Isis we're going to
defeat Isis Isis happened a number of
years ago in a vacuum that was left so
because of bad judgment and I will tell
you
I will take care of Isis
gonna grab Isis by the and much
bigger things just for the record though
are you saying that what you said on
that bus 11 years ago there's a job
actually grab them
without this I have disrespect for women
nobody has more respect for women than I
do so for the representation frankly
and I was embarrassed by it but I have
tremendous respect for women have you
ever done this thing have respect I'm
tremendous and I will tell you no I have
not and I will tell you that I'm going
to make I will tell you we're going to
have borders on our country which we
don't have now people are pouring into
our country and they're coming in from
the Middle East and other places uh
we're going to make America safe again
we're going to make America great again
but we're going to make America safe
again and we're going to make America
wealthy again because if you don't do
that uh it just and it sounds harsh to
say but we have to build up the wealth
of our location now other nations are
taking our jobs and they're taking our
wealth thank you Mr John what I want to
talk about secretary Clinton do you want
to respond
well like everyone else I've spent a lot
of time thinking over the last 48 hours
um thinking about what we heard
you know with prior republican nominees
for president I disagreed with them on
politics policies principles
but I never questioned their Fitness to
serve
Donald Trump is different
I said starting back in June
president and commander-in-chief
and many Republicans and independents
have said the same thing
what we all saw and heard on Friday
was your husband talking about women
art form what he does is women he did
and he has said that the video doesn't
represent who he is
but I think it's clear to anyone who
heard it that it represents exactly who
he is because we've seen this throughout
the campus he's not going to let this go
see he's trying to we have seen him now
she wants to stay away
we've seen him rape women
on their appearance ranking them from
one that's not the same as sexually
assaulting America you've seen him
embarrass women on TV and on Twitter I
embarrass my wife at the mall we saw him
after the first debate it's been nearly
a week
denigrating a former Miss Universe
got fast
personal terms so yes this is who Donald
Trump is
oh by the way sexism card that's like
eight and it's not only this video that
raises questions about his Fitness
because he has also targeted immigrants
African-Americans
Latinos people with disabilities
pows Muslims
so this is who Donald Trump is and the
question for us I think she's a little
sore that he doesn't want to grab him
she's talking to him
I want to send a message we all should
to every boy and girl and indeed to the
entire world
that America already is great but we are
great because we are good that's a good
line and we will respect one another and
we will work with one another and we
will celebrate our diversity
these are very important values to me
because this is the America that I know
and love
and I can pledge to you tonight that
this is the America that I will serve if
I'm so fortunate enough to become your
president
and we want to get to some questions
from online
it's just words folks it's just words
those words I've been hearing them for
many years
I heard them when they
were running for the Senate and your
thoughts dude
for the Senate and she failed I've heard
them where Hillary's constantly talking
about the inner cities of our country
which are a disaster education wise
job-wise safety wise
in every way possible I'm going to help
the African-Americans I'm going to help
the Latinos Hispanics I am going to help
the inner cities she's done a terrible
job for the African-Americans she wants
their vote and she does nothing and then
she comes back four years later we saw
that firsthand when she was a United
States Senator she campaigned where the
Mr Trump Mr Trump I want to get to
audience questions and online questions
so she's allowed to do that but I'm not
allowed to you're going to have you're
going to get to respond right now you
were both asked questions it's not what
the victim thing intense it's like the
David I didn't get enough time
of the entire 2016 election on Facebook
with millions and millions of people
discussing it on the social network
as we said a moment ago we do want to
bring in questions
via social media
and Facebook Trump says the campaign has
changed him when did that happen so Mr
Trump let me add to that when you walked
off that bus at age 59 were you a
different man or did that behavior
continue until just more value from the
debate and you have two minutes for this
no not for us but that was locker room
talk I'm not proud of it I am a person
who has great respect for people from my
family for the people of this country
and certainly people watching it you
want them to win you don't believe that
he cheated on all of his wives with
otherwise you know he doesn't respect
his family you know he doesn't respect
relationships this was action just stop
with the lies you want them to win fine
but stop lying you know he has no
respect for politics particularly his
wives let's just be real
she's a pawn they both suck you can say
any way you want to say it but Bill
Clinton
Hillary Clinton attacked those same
women
and attack them viciously four of them
here tonight here we go one of the women
who is a wonderful woman at 12 years old
was raped at 12. her client
she represented got him off and she's
seen laughing on two separate occasions
laughing at the girl who was raped Kathy
Shelton that young woman is here with us
tonight
so don't tell me about words I am you
snore absolutely I apologize for those
words
but it is things that people say all
right new rule every time he sniffs or
snorts you have to drink impeached he
lost his license to practice law
he had to pay an 850 000 dollar fine to
one of the women
Paula Jones who's also here tonight
and I will tell you that when Hillary
brings up a point like that and she
talks about words that I said 11 years
ago
I think it's disgraceful and I think she
should let's abandon that role
secretary Clinton you have two minutes
that chair's too high for her she can't
sit on it let me start by saying that so
much of what he's just said is not right
but he gets to run his campaign any way
he chooses he gets to decide what he
wants to talk about
instead of answering people's questions
talking about our agenda laying out the
plans that we have that we think can
make a better life and a better country
that's his choice
when I hear something like that I am
reminded of what my friend Michelle
Obama
advised us all
when they go low you go high
no no no she was talking about getting
high with her professor look
she was going to be the first lady she
got high maybe what he's saying tonight
would be understandable
but everyone can draw their own
conclusions at this point about whether
or not the man in the video or the man
on the stage respects women
but he never apologizes for anything to
anyone well he just did he never
apologized to Mr and Mrs Khan
the Gold Star Family the neighbors from
King of the sun Captain Khan died in the
line of duty
with lawn clipping Donald
insulted and attacked them for weeks
over their religion
he never apologized to the distinguished
federal judge he's at resting face
look at him he was born in Indiana look
at that face he is but Donald said he
couldn't be trusted because he's going
to take the bait his parents were quote
Mexican Donald he never apologized to
the reporter that he mimicked and mocked
on National Television
oh come on
that President Obama was not born
in the United States of America he
started president
abroad country an apology and he needs
to take responsibility for his actions
and his words
well you owe the president an apology
because as you know very well is your
campaign Sydney Blumenthal he's another
real winner that you have and he's the
one that got this started along with
your campaign manager and they were on
television just two weeks ago she was
saying exactly that so you really owe
him an apology you're the one that sent
the pictures around your campaign sent
the pictures around you he's taking the
bait right now he's getting distracted I
can't believe this
Crowder are you Amazed by this number do
you think he's taking the debate and I
need to get back on track I can't be the
only one I'm actually kind of happy he's
going after this I've gotten this season
he skimmed over the last time I've ever
seen of Michelle Obama talking about you
Hillary so you talk about friend go back
and take a look at those commercials a
race where you lost
fair and square unlike the Bernie
Sanders race where he won but not fair
and square in my opinion and all you
have to do is take a look at Wikileaks
and just see what they said about oh
there you go laughing
I'm out of here because Bernie Sanders
between super delicious
to see him sign on with the Devil but
when you talk about apology I think the
one that you should really be
apologizing for and the thing that you
should be apologizing for this has been
entirely personally females just think
about it you deleted and that you acid
washed and then the two boxes a pair of
Levi's and other things last week that
were taken from an office and are now
missing and I'll tell you what I didn't
think I'd say this but I'm going to say
it and I hate to say it oh no but if I
win I am going to instruct my attorney
general
to get a special prosecutor to look into
your situation because there has never
been so many lies so much deception
there has never been anything like it
and we're going to have a special
prosecutor when I speak
that's more notable laughing of this
country are Furious in my opinion the
people that have been long-term workers
at the FBI are Furious there has never
been anything like this where emails and
you get a subpoena are you out you get
it I'm getting close after getting the
subpoena you delete 33
000 emails my lovely wife is going to uh
as you would say a very expensive
process my lovely wife is going to go
get us the New Holland poet is 11. you
know what so people have Dragon's Milk
Dragon's Milk Dragon lives have been
destroyed I don't know
I don't know
because everything he just said is
absolutely false but I'm not surprised
in the first debate
the audience needs to calm down here
that it would be impossible to be
fact-checking Donald all the time I'd
never get to talk about anything I want
to do and how we're going to really make
lives better for people so once again go
to hillaryclinton.com we have literally
Trump you can fact check them fat check
fact check him in real time last time at
the first debate we had millions of
people uh fact checking so I expect
we'll have millions more fact checking
uh because you know it is uh it's just
awfully good that someone the feedback
right now on Twitter Donald Trump is not
good of the law in our country
unfortunately because you'd be in jail
secretary Clinton
we want to remind the audience to please
not uh
talk out loud please do not applaud
please not applaud when I make fun of my
girlfriend you want to follow up on
emails you've said you're handling it my
work wife was a mistake he disagreed
with director FBI director James Comey
calling your handling of classified
information quote extremely careless the
FBI said that there were 110 classified
emails that were exchanged eight of
which were top secret and that it was
possible hostile actors did gain access
to those emails you don't call that
extremely careless well Martha first let
me say the question before but I'll
repeat it because I want everyone to
hear it that was a mistake and I take
responsibility for using a personal
email account obviously if I were to do
it over again I would not I'm not making
any excuses not get caught it was a
mistake and I am very uh sorry about
that but I think it's also important uh
to point out it's very uncomfortable
tonight
the server I was using and there is no
no evidence that anyone can point to at
all anyone who says otherwise
that any classified
materials 120 classified materials very
seriously 140 give me give me a little
bit Senator Services committee it was
privy to a lot of classified material
obviously as Secretary of State I had
some of the most important secrets that
we possess such as going after but just
my penis so I am very committed to oh
it's taking classified their information
seriously and as I said there is no
evidence uh that any classes send us
your pictures of the members you were
enjoying ended up in the wrong hands
okay we're going to
the letter c on a document
right she didn't even know what that
word what that letter meant you know
it's amazing I'm watching what's that
Hillary go over facts and she's going
after fact after fact and she's lying
again oh that is good because she said
she you know what she did with emails
was fine you think it was fine to delete
33 000 emails I don't think so she said
the 33 I think the emails had to do with
that daughter's wedding number one well
maybe we'll give three or three or four
or five or something 33 000 emails
deleted and now she's saying there
wasn't anything wrong I won okay
after she got it from the United States
Congress and I'll be honest I am so
disappointed in Congressman including
Republicans second and Twitter for
allowing this to happen our justice
department where her husband goes onto
the back of an airplane for 39 minutes
talks to the attorney general days
before a ruling is going to be made on
her case
but for you to say that there was
nothing wrong with you deleting 39 000
emails again you should be ashamed of
yourself what you did and this is after
getting a subpoena from the United
States
we want to give the audience
in jail let alone after getting a
subpoena from the United States
Secretary Clinton you can respond though
we have to move on to an audience
question look
it's just not true and so please
not well we turned over 35 000. so oh
yeah what about the other 50
000. please allow her to respond she
didn't talk while you talked every time
you interrupted
the first debate and uh I'm going to try
it out during this debate because uh I'd
like to get to the questions that the
people have brought here tonight to talk
to us about and get off this question
okay Donald I know you're in a big
diversion site anything to avoid talking
about your campaign and the way it's
exploding and the way we're not drinking
let's see what happens that people care
about tonight let's get to their
questions we have a question here from
Ken corpowitz he has a question about
health care I'd like to know Anderson
why aren't you bringing up the emails
I'd like to know why aren't you no it
hasn't it hasn't and it hasn't been
finished at all Ken carport says the
questions nice to one on three thank you
Affordable Care is good known as Obama
from the point that out at least it is
not affordable
premiums have gone up deductibles have
gone up co-pays have gone up
prescriptions have gone up on ARP and
the coverage has gone down
because you started out the last one to
the audience
he wants to start he can start just go
ahead no go ahead Donald no I'm a
gentleman Hillary go ahead secretary
Clinton
[Laughter]
by the was about to say he's going
to solve it by repealing it and getting
rid of uh the Affordable Care Act and
I'm gonna fix it because I agree with
you premiums have gotten too high
co-pays deductibles prescription drug
costs and I've laid out a series
to try to get those costs down but
here's what I don't want people to
forget when we're talking about raining
in the cost which has to be the highest
priority of the next president
when the Affordable Care Act passed it
wasn't just that 20 million people got
insurance who didn't have it yes
I meet these people all the time it was
less expensive insurance
but everybody else the 170 million of us
who get health insurance through our
employers
because of a pre-existing condition
number two no lifetime limits
which is a big deal if you have serious
health problems number three as you well
know you charge more than men for our
health insurance which is the way it
used to be before the Affordable Care
Act number four if you're under 26 and
your parents have a policy you can be on
that policy until the age of 26
something that didn't happen before so I
want very much what works and is good
about the Affordable Care Act but we've
got to get costs down we've got to
provide some additional help to small
businesses so that they can afford uh to
provide health insurance
but if we repeal it as Donald has
proposed and start over again sweetheart
all of those benefits I just mentioned
are lost to everybody not just people
who get their health insurance on the
exchange and then we would have to start
all over again right now we are at 90
percent health insurance coverage that's
the highest we've ever been in our
country secretary Clinton so I want us
to get to 100 but get costs down and
keep quality up Mr Trump you have two
minutes
it is such a great question and it's
maybe the question I get almost more
than anything else outside of Defense
Obamacare is a disaster you know it we
all know it
it's going up at numbers that nobody's
ever seen worldwide it's nobody's ever
seen another person is here from the
back like that yeah it's only getting
worse in 17 it implodes by itself
their method of fixing it is to go back
and ask Congress for more money more and
more money and we have right now almost
20 trillion dollars in debt
Obamacare will never work
it's very bad very bad health insurance
far too expensive and not only expensive
for the person that has it unbelievably
expensive for our country it's going to
be one of the biggest line items very
shortly
we have to repeal it and replace it
with something absolutely much less
expensive and something that works
actually be tailored we have to get rid
of the lines around the state artificial
lines we stop insurance companies from
coming in and competing because they
wanted President Obama and whoever was
working on it they want to leave those
lines because that gives the insurance
companies essentially monopolies we want
competition
you will have this is good the finest
healthcare plan there is she wants to go
to a single-payer plan which would be a
disaster
somewhat similar to Canada and if you
ever notice the Canadians when they need
a big operation when something happens
they come into the United States in many
cases true because their their system is
so slow
it's it's catastrophic in certain ways
but she wants to go to single-payer
which means the government basically
rules everything Hillary Clinton has
been after this for years Obamacare was
the first step Obamacare is a total
disaster and not only are your rates
going now for him by numbers that
nobody's ever believed but your
deductibles are going up so that unless
you get hit by a truck you're never
going to be able to use it
disastrous plan and it has to be
repealed and replaced secretary Clinton
let me follow up with you your husband
called Obamacare quote the craziest
thing in the world saying that small
business owners are getting killed is
premiums double coverage is cut in half
was he mistaken or was his mistake
simply telling the truth no
situation in entry where if we were to
start all over again
we might come up with a difference you
forget the sense that that suit was just
an employer-based system that's where
that's like a snail you take it out of a
shell and you feel sad
Ness
between people who were too poor and um
any resources to afford health care
namely people on Medicaid I do now if I
can find one little bastard which is a
single-payer system salt which tastes
carrots are elderly and does a great job
doing it by the way and then all the
people who were employed but people who
were working but didn't have the money
to afford insurance and didn't have
anybody an employer or anybody else to
help them well why would you block
insurance from across state lines the
slot that the Obamacare uh that doesn't
make any sense that's one thing if
someone can tweet me why they would be
opposed to opening Insurance across
state lines that's another one I've
never heard of valid arguments
Donald's not telling you against that we
just turn it back to the insurance
companies the way it used to be and that
Obamacare was the biggest Institute it
was the biggest Kickback for insurance
companies there's ever been and then
they go out and vilify insurance
companies what they did is force
everybody to buy insurance for the
government punishes you so you still
have to purchase private insurance if
the government punishes you without
putting any kind of limitation or any
kind of regulations on prices so what
have insurance companies done they've
astronomically raised your premiums
that's why you're paying so much more
they gave insurance companies the best
deal possible don't believe the BS she's
selling them everything number two
Bernie Sanders said that Hillary Clinton
has very bad judgment this is a perfect
example of it trying to save Obamacare
which is you said you want to end
Obamacare you said you want to end
Obamacare you've also said you want to
make coverage that looks like a bread
soups how do you force insurance
companies to do that if you're no longer
mandated a little cheddar broccoli in
there you're going to have plans what
does that mean well I'll tell you what
I've been
that are so good because we're going to
have so much competition in the
insurance industry once we break out
once we break out the lines and allow
the competition to come are you going to
have a mandate that Americans have to
have health insurance excuse me you have
to stop breaking the rules the boundary
lines around each state and it was
almost gone until just three toward the
end of the passage of Obamacare
which by the way was a fraud you know
that because Jonathan Gruber the
architect of Oklahoma was said it's
another word it's a great lie it was a
big lie President Obama said you keep
your doctor you keep your plan the whole
thing was a fraud and it doesn't work
but when we get rid of those lines you
have competition and we will be able to
keep pre-existing we'll also be able to
help people that can't get don't have
money because we are going to have
people protected and Republicans feel
this way believe it or not and strongly
this way we're going to block grant into
the states we're going to block grant
into Medicaid so that we will be able to
take care of people without the
necessary funds to take care of
themselves thanks Mr Trump we now go to
gorba Hamid with a question we should
drink for every button you have
go
all right there are 3.3 million Muslims
in the United States and I'm one of them
you've mentioned working with Muslim
nations
how will you help like me deal with the
consequences of being labeled as a
threat to the country after the election
is over well Mr Trump here
Food suppliers starts islamophobia and
that's a shame
but one thing we have to do is we have
to make sure that because there is a
problem I mean whether we like it or not
and we can be very politically correct
but whether we like it or not there is a
problem and we have to be sure that
Muslims come in and Report when they see
something going on when they see hatred
going on they have to report it as an
example in San Bernardino
many people saw the bombs all over the
apartment of the two people that killed
14 and wounded many many people horribly
wounded they'll never be the same
Muslims have to report
[Music]
the problems when certainly his mic is
crappy this time
you know there's a boy who cried
microphone if they don't do that it's a
very difficult situation for our country
because you look at Orlando what are you
doing and you look at the World Trade
Center
these are radical Islamic terrorists and
she won't even mention the word and nor
will President Obama
radical Islamic terrorism now to solve a
problem you have to be able to State
what the problem is or at least say grab
another she won't say the name and
President Obama won't say the name but
the name is there it's radical Islamic
Terror and before you solve it you have
to say the name
secretary Clinton
well thank you for asking your question
and I've heard this question from a lot
of Muslim Americans namely the
terrorists who you invited dinner
parties because
very divisive dark things said about
Muslims and even someone like Captain
Khan the young man who sacrificed
himself defending our country in the
United States Army has been subject to
attack by Donald
I want to say just a couple of things
first we've had Muslims in America since
George Washington
and we've had drinking game is making me
hate the only things that I love a
particularly well-known one with
Muhammad Ali
my vision of America
where it was everyone has a place if
you're willing to work hard you do your
part tribute to the community
slide under the rugs we want America to
be for our children send a few
pedophiles it's also very short-sighted
and even dangerous to be engaging in the
kind of demagogic rhetoric that Donald
has about Muslims
we need American Muslims to be part of
our eyes and ears on our front lines
I've worked with a lot of different
Muslim groups around America I've met
with a lot of them and I've heard how
important it is for them to feel that
they are wanted and included and part of
our country part of our homeland
security and that's what I want to see
it's also important I intend to defeat
Isis to do so in a coalition with
majority Muslim nations right now a lot
of those nations are hearing what Donald
says and wondering
why should we cooperate with the
Americans and this is a gift to Isis
these Muslims have got a lot of respect
for you Mrs terrorists we are not at War
thanks for going to listen to her the
one with the dirty Harry haircuts
and Sudden Impact yes that's one country
where citizens
family are just as welcome as anyone
else thank you secretary
Donald J Trump is calling for a total
and complete shutdown of Muslims
entering the United States until our
country's Representatives can figure out
what the hell is going on we have no
choice we have no choice your running
mate said this week that the Muslim ban
is no longer your position is that
correct and if it is was it a mistake to
have a religious test first of all
Captain Khan is an American Hero and if
I were president at that time he would
be alive today
because unlike her who voted for the war
without knowing what she was doing I
would not have had our people in Iraq
Iraq was a disaster
so he would have been alive today
the Muslim ban is something that in some
form has morphed into a extreme vetting
from certain areas of the world Hillary
Clinton
wants to allow
and why did it morph into that no should
you not answer the question
please explain whether or not the Muslim
ban still Donald Trump I'll give you
permission
yes we are going to area Syria where
they're coming in by the tens of
thousands because of Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton wants to allow a 550
percent increase over Obama people are
coming into our country like we have no
idea who they are where they're what's
on your assistance
and she wants five years she's going to
be the great Trojan Horse Billy Clinton
we have enough problems in this country
I believe in building safe zones I will
even having other people pay for them as
an example the Gulf States who are not
carrying their weight but they have
nothing but money
and take care of people but I don't want
to have with all the problems this
country has and all of the problems that
you see going on
hundreds of thousands of people coming
in from Syria when we know nothing about
them we know nothing about their values
and we know nothing about their love for
our country and secretary Clinton let me
ask you about that her name is Martha
Raditz asked for an increase from 10 to
6 '5
Syrian refugees
we know you want tougher vetting that's
not a perfect system so why take the
risk of having those refugees come into
the country well first of all I will not
let anyone into our country that I think
poses a risk to us you heard her say
supporting bill of refugees
women and children think of that picture
we all saws
you're taking less than 0.5 Christian
refugees even though they make up 10 of
the population why don't you take in
more Christian refugees you're not
you're taking in Muslim Russian battle
aged men and we need to do our
partrails are carrying anywhere near the
load that Europe and others
we will have vetting that is as tough as
it needs to be from our professionals
our intelligence experts and others
but it is important for us as a I've
been holding on to that one let's see
you know not to say as Donald has said
we're going to ban People based on a
religion
how do you do that we are a country
founded on religious freedom and liberty
how do we
do what he has advocated without causing
great distress within our own country
are we going to have religious tests
to be able to implement those so I
thought that what he said was it was
extremely unwise and even dangerous and
indeed you can look at the propaganda on
a lot of the terrorist sites
and what Donald Trump says about Muslims
is used to recruit what do they say
about women showing their face hilly
because they want to create a war
between us and the final thing I would
say yes and it doesn't matter what
Donald
terrorists that are going to wage
looked at it it's been debunked but it
never stops him from saying whatever he
wants it's not been debunked so please
and you can see it I was against the war
in Iraq has not been debunked and you
voted for it and you shouldn't have well
I just there's been lots of fact
checking on that I'd like to move on to
an online question she just went about
25 seconds over her time because I just
respond to this please very quickly
please
Hillary Clinton in terms of having
people come into our country we have
many criminal illegales are we missing
Donald from Hillary sent them back
thanks for letting us know we don't want
them in some cases their murderers drug
lords drugs no no no no no
and Hillary Clinton was a real Secretary
of State said that's okay we can't force
it into their country let me tell you
I'm going to force them right back into
that country they're murderers and some
very bad people and I will tell you very
strongly when Bernie Sanders said she
had bad judgment she has really bad
judgment because we are letting people
into this country that are going to
cause problems and crime like you've
never seen we're also letting drugs pour
through our Southern border at a record
clip at a record clip and it shouldn't
be allowed to happen ice just endorsed
me they've never endorsed the
presidential candidate the border patrol
agents 16 500 just recently endorsed me
and they endorse me because I understand
the Border she doesn't she wants amnesty
for everybody come right in come right
over it's a horrible thing she's doing
she's got bad judgment and honestly new
rules
visiting our website president of the
United States thank you Mr Trump I want
to move on this next question yeah
naturally you do because that was bad
for Hillary that was good for Trump bad
for Hillary debate coalitions online
Forum where Americans submitted
questions that generated millions of
votes this question involves Wikileaks
release of purported excerpts of
secretary Clinton's paid speeches which
she has refused to release and one line
in particular in which you secretary
Clinton say you need both a public and
private position on certain issues so
two from Virginia asks is it okay for
politicians to be two-faced is it
acceptable for a politician to have a
private stance please ask her about
that was something I said about Abraham
Lincoln as I recall that was something I
said when I was being a Steven
Spielberg movie called Lincoln
it was a master class
president Lincoln get the Congress to
approve the 13th Amendment
it was principled and it was strategic
and I was making the point that it is
hard sometimes to get the Congress to do
what you want to do and you have to keep
working at it and yes President Lincoln
was trying to convince some people he's
facing some arguments other people he
used other arguments was a great uh I
thought great
of presidential leadership
let's talk about what's really going on
here Martha because
that the Kremlin meaning Putin and the
Russian government I didn't like
Gremlins I preferred the sequel the
attacks the hacking on American accounts
to influence our election
Wikileaks is part of that as our other
sites where the Russians hack
information we don't even know if it's
accurate information and then they put
it out
of our country been in a situation where
an adversary a foreign power is working
so hard to influence the outcome of as
he says he agrees with a lot of what
Putin wants to do maybe because he wants
to do business in Moscow I don't know
the reasons but we deserve answers and
we should demand that Donald release all
of his tax returns so that people can
see what are the entanglements and the
financial
look now she's blaming she got caught in
a total lie her papers went out to all
her friends at the banks Goldman Sachs
and everybody else and she said things
Wikileaks that just came out
and she also said she wanted to run
against you up Donald on the late great
Abraham Lincoln that's one that I have
okay honest tape honest tape never lied
that's the good thing that's the big
difference between Abraham Lincoln and
you
that's a big big difference we're
talking about some difference
but
now he's trying to find himself back
other moments of what he was saying I
don't know Putin
I think it would be great if we get
along with Russia because we could fight
Isis together as an example but I don't
know
anytime anything wrong happens they like
to say the Russians the Russian doesn't
know if it's the Russians doing the
hacking maybe there is no hacking but
they always blame Russia and the reason
they blame Russia because they think
they're trying to tarnish me with Russia
I know nothing about Russia I know I
know about Russia but I know nothing
about the inner workings of Russia I
don't deal there I have no businesses
that have no loans
on Pennsylvania Avenue the United States
government because of my balance sheet
which they actually know very well
chose me to do the old post office
between the White House and Congress
chose me to do the Old Post Office one
of the primary things in fact perhaps
the primary thing was balance sheet
but I have no loans with Russia you
could go to the United States government
and they would probably tell you that
because they know my sheet very well in
order to get that development I had to
have now the taxes are a very simple
thing as soon as I have first of all I
pay hundreds of millions of dollars in
taxes none of them are answering the
questions
this is rambling this is two people in
the old folks home uh they're fighting
each other
it's like it's like two guys two MC's
trying to fill time before the main act
shows up on stage
got a good knock knock joke I pay
hundreds of millions of dollars in taxes
where are you from Sir Milwaukee
there's nothing funny
anyone here from Green Bay
turn actually the topic of taxes we have
a question from Spencer Moss Spencer
Spencer which I'm a Russians meddling
election what about Hillary's foreign
donations
will you change to ensure the wealthiest
Americans pay their fair share in taxes
Mr Trump you have two minutes some
carried interest the one of the greatest
I think you just walked offset of
Twilight five
I give up a lot when I run because
I knock out the tax code and she could
have done this years ago by the way
she's a United States she was a United
States Senator she complains that Donald
Trump took advantage of the tax cut well
why didn't she change it why didn't you
change it there was a girl named tax
calculator
Provisions in the tax code but frankly
we could change
but you wouldn't change it because all
of these people give you the money so
you can take negative ads on Donald
Trump
but and I say that about a lot of things
you know I've heard Hillary complaining
about so many different things over the
years I wish you'd have done this but
she's been there for
death and doing this stuff
for Change and she
knows she never will change we're
getting rid of carried interest
Provisions I'm lowering taxes actually
because I think it's so important for
corporations because we have
corporations leaving massive
corporations and little ones little ones
she looks like when they cry
taxes for the middle class and I will
tell you we are cutting a big league for
the middle class and I will tell you
Hillary Clinton is raising your taxes
folks you could look at me she's raising
your tax legs
and mounted a cabbage patch kit is a
disaster for the country but she is
raising your taxes and I'm lowering your
taxes that in itself is a big difference
we have no growth let's make this Lively
here
inside
it's like no growth and we're going
lower in my opinion and a lot of it has
to do with the fact that our taxes are
so high just about the highest in the
world
in the world
and I think it's so important one of the
most important things in his mouth she's
raising everybody's taxes
the question was uh what specific tax
Provisions were changing for the
wealthiest Americans pay their fair
share of taxes
well everything why don't you go back to
yourself
I'm sorry I have to keep saying this but
he lives in an alternative oh my God
Logan Hamill is bringing Cobra sort of
amusing to hear somebody who hasn't paid
federal income taxes in maybe 20 years
talking about what he's going to do but
I'll tell you what he's going to do his
I know what he's going to do
healthy and corporations
biggest tax cuts they've ever had more
than the Bush tax cuts by at least a
factor of two Bush tax cuts benefited
middle class and people like Donald and
this would be a massive gift and indeed
the way that he talks about his tax cuts
would end up raising taxes on middle
class families millions of middle-class
families no now here's what I wanted no
it wouldn't that's fine nobody who makes
lessons
will have their taxes raised because I
think we've got to go where the money is
and the money is with people who've
taken advantage of every single break in
the tax code and yes when I was a
senator I did vote to close corporate
loopholes I voted to close I think one
of the loopholes he took advantage of
when he claimed a billion dollar
loss that enabled him to avoid paying
taxes I want to have a tax on people if
a business owner loses almost a billion
dollars why should they have to pay
taxes yes Warren Buffett people just
assume that that's really silly somebody
like him should not be paying a lower
tax rate than his secretary I want to
have a surch
up for lost times because I want to
invest in you I want to invest in
hard-working families and I think it's
been unfortunate but you buzzed yet
someone said it happened that since the
Great Recession the gains ever so
slightly and we need to reverse that
because
for our vets for our military zero for
health and education that is wrong and
we're going to make sure that nobody no
Corporation
taxes employee
guess what we're saying you have not
answered though a simple question did
you use that 99 16 million dollars
grabbing by the of course I
said so do all of her donors or most of
her donors I know many of her donors
please
because you avoid Health all this money
they wanted that's why tax code better
than anybody that's ever run for
president Hillary Clinton and it's
extremely complex Hillary Clinton has
friends that want all of these
Provisions
but they really want the carried
interest provision which I believe
Hillary's leaving it's very interesting
why she's leaving carried interest but I
will tell you that number one I pay
tremendous numbers of taxes I absolutely
used it and so did Warren Buffett and so
did George Soros and so did many of the
other people that Hillary is uh getting
money from now I won't mention their
names because they're rich but they're
not famous so we won't make them famous
can you can you say how many years you
have avoided paying personal federal
income taxes no but I pay tax and I pay
federal tax too but I have a write-off a
lot of it's depreciation which is a
wonderful charge I love depreciation you
know she's given it to us hey if she had
a problem for 30 years she's been doing
this Anderson I say it all the time she
talks about health care why didn't you
do something about it she talks about
taxes why didn't she do something about
it she she doesn't do anything about
anything other than talk with her it's
all talk and no action in the past and
again Bernie Sanders it's really bad
judgment she has made bad judgment not
only on taxes
on Libya on Syria on Iraq I mean her and
Obama I think this is where Trump has
not a strong Susie he just bring it back
to it feels so bad why haven't done
anything about it
first place they started from that
limited time he can be taught 32
different nations Hillary
congratulations great job once you be
able to respond secretary Clinton
well here we go again I've been in favor
of getting rid of carried interest for
years
um starting when I was a senator from
New York she lied but that's not the
point why didn't you do it why didn't
you do it because I was a Senator with a
Republican president oh really I will be
the president if you were an effective
if you were an effective Senator you
could have done it if you were an
effective Senator you could have done it
but you were not an offense allowed to
respond she didn't interrupt you you
know
presidents have something called these
little silver held
very glad to do so it smells like money
eight million kids every year
this lady I worked with Democrats and
Republicans to create the children's
health insurance program
hundreds of thousands of kids now have a
chance to be adopted because after
husband change our adoption and foster
care system after 9 11. to work with
Republicans
to rebuild New York and to get health
care for our First Responders who are
suffering because they had run toward
danger and gotten sickened by it
hundreds of thousands of National Guard
and Reserve members have health care
because of work that I did and children
have safer medicines because I was able
to pass a law that required the dosing
to be more carefully done when I was
Secretary of State I went around the
dosing on your advocacy as a foreign
country but also advocating for women's
rights to make sure that women had a
decent
chance to have a better life and
negotiated a treaty with Russia to lower
nuclear weapons
too co-sponsor when I was a senator for
eight years
I worked very hard and was very proud to
be re-elected in New York by an even
bigger margin than I had been elected
the first time I'd never lived but I had
an apartment for three weeks I didn't
take that work that totally counts that
finding common ground because you have
to be able to get along with people to
get things done in Washington thank you
secretary and I've proven that I can and
for 30 years I've produced results thank
you secretary we're going to move on to
Syria both of you have mentioned that
she said a lot of things and I think we
should we could no Mr Trump we're going
to go on this thank you Hayden Florida
we're going to move on
the heartbreaking video of a
five-year-old Syrian boy named Omron
sitting in an ambulance after being
pulled from the rubble Rubble after an
airstrike
focused the world's attention on the
horrors of the war in Syria
on Facebook
there are much worse images coming out
of Aleppo every day now not any worse
than you sitting at that table
sweetheart 400. harambe nightmares 100
of them children just days ago the state
department called for a war crimes
investigation of the Syrian regime of
Bashar al-assad and its Ally Russia
Young Turks for their bombardment of
Elections
from social media through just keep this
on Diane's from Pennsylvania asks if you
were president what would you do about
Syria and the humanitarian crisis in
Aleppo isn't it a lot like when the U.S
waited too long before we helped
secretary Clinton we will begin with
your two minutes
well the situation in Syria
married my wife this is true every day
goes by we see the results of the regime
uh by Assad in partnership with the
Iranians on the ground the Russians in
the air more uncomfortable if you like
firmly bombarding places like a funny
creepy where they're hundreds of
thousands of people probably about 250
000 still left
and there is a determined effort by the
Russian Air Force
Aleppo in partnership with the Iranians
on the ground the Russians in the air
you got The Young Turks bombarding
places in particular Aleppo all right
where there are hundreds of thousands of
people probably about 250 000 still left
and there was a determined effort by the
Russian Air Force to destroy Aleppo in
order to eliminate the last of the
Syrian rebels who are really holding out
against the Assad regime
Russia hasn't paid any attention to Isis
they're interested in keeping Assad in
power
so I when I was Secretary of State
advocated and I advocate today a no-fly
zone and safe Zone we need some leverage
with the Russians uh because they're not
going to come to the negotiating table
for a diplomatic uh resolution
is that the other one
and the aggressiveness of Russia
I've taken on Putin and others it's just
me our livestream is so much better
wherever we can cooperate with Russia
that's fine and I did as Secretary of
State that's how we got 35 of
independent voters think you're a dick
that's how we got the sanctions on Iran
that seems like a low number Stephen
seems like a low number without firing a
single shot so I would go to the
negotiating table with more leverage
they're nonsensical I do support the
effort to investigate for crimes war
crimes committed by the Assyrians and
the Russians and try to hold them
accountable thank you secretary was
there a secretary of state with the
so-called Line in the Sand
which no I wasn't I was gone I hate to
interrupt you but but you were in
contact excuse me you were in total
context excuse me and perhaps sadly
Obama probably still listened to you I
don't think he'd be listening very much
anymore Obama draws the Line in the Sand
it was
laughed at all over the world what
happened now with that being said
she talks tough against Russia
but our nuclear program has fallen way
behind and they've gone
wild with their nuclear program not good
our government shouldn't have allowed
that to happen Russia is new in terms of
Young Turks yeah they're pretty quiet
aren't they tired we're exhausted in
terms of at some point you guys say are
they providing anything are the young
troops providing anything they better be
hit with a copyright strike yeah they're
doing nothing and against especially
sitting there eating Ducks
denying The Armenian Genocide just
levels of course being reasonable right
yes
we tune in oh Jesus
Gaddafi is out it's a mess and by the
way Isis has a good chunk of their oil
I'm sure you probably have heard that it
was a disaster
everything she's done foreign
we sign a peace treaty everyone's all
excited well what Russia did and with
Assad who you've made very powerful with
the dumbest deal perhaps I've ever seen
in the history of deal making the Iran
deal with 150 billion dollars with the
1.7 billion in cash which is enough cash
to fill up this room
but look at look at that deal Iran now
and Russia are now against us only one
problem you don't even know who the
rebels are Mr Trump
one thing I have to say shut up Martha
nobody likes you God is killing Isis
Russia is killing Isis and Iran is
killing Isis and those three have now
lined up because of our weakness
Mr Trump let me repeat the question
by the
sometimes crisis in Aleppo and I want to
remind you what your running mate said
he said provocations by Russia need to
be met with American strength and that
if Russia continues to be involved in
airstrikes along with the Syrian
government forces of Assad the United
States of America should be prepared to
use military force
military targets of the Assad regime
okay he and I haven't spoken I disagree
I disagree disagree with you knock out
Isis right now Syria is fighting Isis we
have people that will fight both at the
same time but Syria is no longer series
I'm sorry I was hoping they were going
to give some commentary
commentary
very very quickly
they think a lot of the Isis leaders are
in Russell so we have announcements
coming out of Washington and coming out
of Iraq we will be attacking mosul in
three weeks crazy those guys are
crisis are leaving muscle why can't they
do it quietly a lot of people are saying
make it he needs to stop standing behind
the chair it's almost like he's hiding
he's behind it it's a little awkward
from the American public that we've
knocked out the leaders we've had a
tremendous success people leave why do
they have to say we're going to be
attacking mosul within the next four to
six weeks which is what they're saying
how stupid is our country there are
sometimes reasons the military does that
psychological Wars I can't think of
anything it might be to help get
civilians out and we have look I have
200 generals and who endorse me I have
21 Congressional Medal of Honor
recipients who endorse me we talk about
it in her defense all the time all the
terrorists why can't they share
something secretively where they go in
and they knock
out the leadership how why would these
people stay there I've been reading now
tell me what your strategy is for weeks
about muscle that it's the harbor of
where you know between raqqa and mosul
this is where they think the Isis
leaders are why would they be saying
they're not staying there anymore
they're gone because everybody's talking
about how Iraq which is us with our
leadership goes into fight muscle now
with these 200 Admirals and Generals
they can't believe it all I say is this
General George Patton general Douglas
MacArthur are spinning in their grave at
the stupidity of what we're doing in the
Middle East I'm going to go to secretary
Clinton Secretary Clinton you want Assad
to go you advocated arming Rebels but it
looks like that may be too late for
Aleppo you talk about diplomatic efforts
those have failed ceasefires have failed
would you introduce the threat look at
my screen of course
tell me she doesn't look like it oh yeah
I would not uh use American ground
forces in Syria I think that would be a
very serious mistake I don't think
American troops should be
holding territory which is what they
would have to do how many abortions do
you think Force I don't think that is a
smart stream I do think that you will
say Special Forces which we're using uh
the use of enablers and trainers in Iraq
actually
too much interests and so I do support
as soon as she slept with men eight
separate times
at least unless whom was bisexual before
they had a session together she's only
got like a 20 chance each month of
getting pregnant Isis out of Iraq
because they're a lot of credit what
good chance that we can take mosul what
are the chances Donald says
raping somebody else he doesn't uh
they're uh 100 very important planning
going on and some of it is to Signal do
you think it's a Young Turks live stream
Our Lives as well
it takes a lot of planning and
preparation I would go after baghdadi I
would specifically Target baghdadi
because I think is the worst moderator
so far says Tony I agree but the problem
is operations
so I think that could help
that are arming the Kurds the Kurds have
been our best Partners in Syria as well
as Iraq and I know there's a lot of
concern about that and some circles but
I think they should have the equipment
they need air providers on the ground
are the principles that we take raqqa
after pushing us thank you very much we
went over a minute over and you don't
stop her when I go one second over it's
like you had many answers it's really
very interesting got a question over
here from uh James Carter Mr Carter
here's the thing even if that's not true
I think he's probably right people hear
him saying it is smart
believe
you can be a devoted
president
in the United States
I mean she calls
are people deplorable
an irredeemable
I will be a president
and we'll give strength
to people and will give economics to
people and will bring jobs back because
NAFTA signed by her husband is perhaps
the greatest disaster trade deal in the
history of the world not in this country
it stripped us of manufacturing jobs
we lost our jobs we lost our money we
lost our plans it is a disaster and now
she wants to sign TPP even though she
says now she's four she called it the
gold standard and by the way at the last
debate she lied because it turned out
that she did say the gold standard and
she said she didn't say they actually
said that she lied the price is wrong
despite about a lot of things I would be
a president of the people
African-Americans the inner cities
devastating what's happening in the
cities she's been talking about it for
years as usual there I was she talking
suddenly nothing happens
same with the Latino Americans the
Hispanic Americans the same exact thing
they talk they don't get it done you go
into the inner cities and you see it's
45 poverty it's good though
African-Americans now 45 poverty in the
inner cities they prefer the terms
essentially sensitive at all I mean it's
you know I and I've been saying it big
speeches where I have 20 and 30 000
people
what do you have to lose it can't get
any worse and she's been talking about
the inner cities for 25 years
nothing's going to ever happen let me
tell you if she's president of the
United States nothing's going to happen
it's just going to be talking all of her
friends the taxes we were talking about
and I would just get it by osmosis she's
not doing any me favors but by doing all
the others favors she's doing me favors
but but I will tell you she's a great
talk let me tell you it doesn't get done
all you have to do is take a look at a
senate run take a look at upstate New
Yorker two minutes is up secretary
Clinton disaster you have two minutes
secretary Clinton well
67 percent of the people voted to
re-elect me when I ran for my second
time and I was very proud and very
humbled by that Mr Carter never been
humble in your life under thighs I have
tried my entire life
to do what I can to support families
it's greased Lightman law school I went
to work for the children's defense fund
and Donald talks a lot about yeah you
know giving some of that dough to your
husband's 50 years I've been in public
service I'm proud of that you know I
started off as a young lawyer working
against discrimination against
African-American children
I work to make sure that kids with
disabilities to get a public education
something that I care very much about
work with Latinos one of my first jobs
in politics was down in South Texas
registering Latino citizens to be able
to vote
so um
every American feels like he or she has
a place in our country
and I think when you look at the letters
that I get a lot of people are worried
that maybe they wouldn't have a place in
Donald Trump's America
they write me and one woman wrote me
about her son Felix she adopted him from
Ethiopia when he was a toddler he's 10
years old now this is the only country
he's ever known and he listens to Donald
on TV and he said to his mother one day
Donald will he send me back to Ethiopia
if he gets elected
children
is being said to go back to the very
very first question I need to switch to
it and there's a lot of fear that in
fact teachers and parents are calling it
the Trump effect bullying is up a lot of
people are feeling you know uneasy
concerns
and foremost
I will do everything I can to reach out
to everybody Democrats Republicans
Independents people across our country
if you don't vote for me I'm still want
to be your president you're going to be
the best president I can be for every
American Secretary Clinton you're two
minutes is up I want to follow up on
something that Donald Trump actually
said to you uh a comment you made last
month you said that half of Donald Trump
supporters are quote deplorables racist
sexist homophobic xenophobic
islamophobic later said you regretted
saying half you didn't Express regret
for using the term deplorative
deplorables to Mr Carter's question how
can you unite a country if you've
written off tens of millions of
Americans well within hours I I said
that I was sorry about the way I I
talked about that because I think he's
always been not with his better
moderator than most he's been Anderson
yeah he's no doubt biased but I think
he's been more fair than most models not
her not the Martha very no no him
Anderson kinds of comments about not
just women but all Americans all kinds
of Americans he's so tiny
I think that
a lot of the tone and tenor that he has
said I'm proud of the campaign that
Bernie Sanders and Iran we ran a
campaign based on issues not insults and
he is supporting me a hundred percent
because we talked about what we wanted
to do we might have had some differences
and we had a lot of debates
that could make the country better and I
was proud of that I'll give you a minute
we have a divided nation
we have a very divided nation you look
at Charlotte okay you look at Baltimore
you look at the violence that's taking
place in the inner cities Chicago you
take a look at Washington D.C we have a
increase in Murder within our cities the
biggest in 45 years we have a divided
nation because people like her and
believe me
she has tremendous hate in her heart and
when she said the police she meant it
and when she said irredeemable they're
irredeemable you didn't mention that but
when she said they're irredeemable to me
that might have been even worse
she's got tremendous hatred
and this country cannot take another
four years of Barack Obama and that's
what you're getting with her Mr Trump
let me follow up with you in 2008 you
wrote in one of your books that the most
important characteristic of a good
leader is discipline you said if a
leader doesn't have it quote he or she
won't be one for very long in the days
after the first debate you sent out a
series of tweets from 3 A.M to 5 a.m
including one that told people to check
out his sex tape is that the discipline
of goodness
just take a look at the person that she
built up to be this wonderful uh Girl
Scout who was no Girl Scout by the way
just so you understand
she said was fat in the morning
guess what
she didn't answer because when
Ambassador Stevens the question is
600 times well she said she was awake at
three o'clock in the morning and she
also sent a tweet out at three o'clock
in the morning but I won't even mention
that but she said she'll be awake the
famous thing we're going to answer our
call at three o'clock in the morning
guess what happened Ambassador Stevens
Ambassador
600 requests for help
and the only one she talked to was
Sydney Blumenthal who's her friend and
not a good guy by the way so you know
she shouldn't be talking about that now
tweeting happens to be a modern day form
of communication I mean you could like
it or not like it I have between
Facebook and Twitter I have almost 25
million people it's a very effective way
of communication so you can put it down
but it is a very effective form of
communication I'm not unproud of it to
be honest with you secretary Clinton
does Mr Trump have the discipline to be
a good leader
no I'm shocked to hear that
well it's
late my opinion
opinion of
many others National Security Experts
Republicans former Republican members of
Congress but it's in part because
those of us who have had the great
privilege of seeing
this job up close and know how difficult
it is and it's not just because I
watched my husband take a 300 billion
dollars
and 23 million new jobs and incomes went
up for everybody everybody
and it's not just because I worked with
George W bush after 9 11.
and I was very proud that when I told
him what the city needed what we needed
to recover he said you've got it and he
never wavered he stuck with me
and I have worked and I admire President
Obama he inherited the worst financial
crisis since the Great Depression
that was a terrible time for our country
we have to move along nine million
people secretary 5 million homes were
lost secretary Clinton billion dollars
in family wealth was wiped out we are
back on the right track he would send us
a participation session with his taxes
[Music]
secretary Clinton we want to get to the
audience
thank you very much both of you
we have another audience question Beth
Miller question for both candidates
that's the most important aspect of this
election is the Supreme Court Justice
what would you prioritize as the most
important aspect of selecting a Supreme
Court Justice here we go first
Secretary Clinton thank you well you're
right this is one of the most important
uh issues in this election first make
sure they don't believe in the Second
Amendment
the world really works who have real
life experience who have not just been
in a big law firm and maybe clerk for a
judge and then gotten on the bench but
you know maybe they tried some more
cases they actually understand what
people are up against because I think
the current court has gone in the wrong
direction
and so I would want to see uh the
Supreme Court uh reverse Citizens United
and get dark unaccountable money out of
our politics Donald doesn't agree with
that I would like the submission United
which was about a film being made
criticizing her and they tried to shut
down that we don't do everything we can
to make it possible for people of color
and older people and young people to be
able to exercise their franchise
I want a supreme court that will stick
with Roe v Wade and a woman's right to
choose and I want a supreme court that
will stick with marriage is tweeting
history
and reverse marriage equality I think
that would be a terrible mistake and
would take us back we just I want a
supreme court that doesn't always side
corporate interests I want a supreme
court that understands because you're
wealthy and you can give more money to
something doesn't mean you have any more
rights or should have any more rights
than anybody else so I have very clear
views about what the right to rape
without contact change the balance on
the Supreme Court and I regret deeply
that the Senate has not done its job and
they have not permitted a vote on the
person that President Obama a highly
qualified person
they've not given him a vote to be able
to have the full complement of nine
Supreme Court Justices I think that was
a dereliction of Duty I hope that they
will see their way to doing it but if I
am so fortunate enough as to be
president I will immediately move to
make sure that we fill that we have nine
thank you secretary Clinton notice half
of our people intentionally I think
Justice sidestepped any second amendment
issues there because she knows losing
issue even though she believes in it she
knows it's losing
Scalia
I'm looking for judges and I've actually
picked 20 of them
so that people would say highly
respected highly thought of and actually
very beautifully reviewed by beautifully
just about everybody but people that
will respect the Constitution oh that's
not a good angle it looks like men
this is so important also the Second
Amendment which is totally underseen
that's why people like Hillary Clinton
they'll respect the Second Amendment and
what it stands for what it represents go
into it because he knows that's a
winning issue now Hillary mentioned
something about uh
so I will have in my race more than a
hundred million dollars put in of my
money meaning I'm not taking all of this
big money from all of these different
corporations like she's doing what I ask
is this so I'm putting in more than by
the time it's finished I'll have more
than 100 million dollars you email me
every day asking for money
for the Republicans you asked me to have
a lunch with Eric Trump
I asked Hillary why does oh I think she
made 250 million dollars
by being in office
she used the power of her office to make
a lot of money that's true why isn't she
but why don't you put 10 or 20 or 25 or
30 million dollars into your own
campaign it's 30 million dollars less
for special interest that will tell you
exactly what to do
and it would really I think be a nice
sign
to the American public why aren't you
putting some money in you have a lot of
it you've made a lot of it because of
the fact that you've been in office
you've made a lot of it while you were
Secretary of State actually so why
aren't you putting money into your own
campaign I'm just curious thank you very
much thank you we're going to get on to
one more question the question was about
the Supreme Court and I just want to
quickly say very quickly I respect the
Second Amendment no you don't no you
don't no you don't no you don't there
should be comprehensive and we should
close
and close the online loophole we have we
have one more question as we possibly
can
bone energy policy
sorry sweetheart you don't have to hear
this what steps will your energy policy
take to meet our energy
Administration under absolute Siege
the EPA Environmental Protection Agency
is killing these energy companies and
foreign companies are now coming in
buying our buying so many of our
different accounts and then rejiggering
the plant so that they can take care of
their oil we are killing my cocktails
absolutely killing our energy business
in this country now I'm all for grabbing
by the persons of energy including wind
including
Etc but we need much more than wind and
solar and you look at our miners Hillary
Clinton wants to put all the minors out
of business
there is a thing called clean coal Coal
will last for a thousand years in this
country now we have natural gas and so
many other things because of Technology
we have unbelievable we have found over
the last seven years we have found
tremendous wealth right under our feet
so good especially when you have 20
trillion in debt I will bring our energy
companies back they'll be able to
compete they'll make money they'll pay
off our national debt they'll pay off
our tremendous budget deficits which are
are tremendous but we are putting our
energy companies out of business we have
to bring back our workers
fracking employment in any other sector
under Obama essentially is killing our
steel workers and our steel companies
we have to guard our energy companies we
have to make it possible the EPA is so
restrictive that they are putting our
energy companies out of business and all
you have to do is go to a great place
like West Virginia or places like Ohio
which is phenomenal or places like
Pennsylvania and you see what they're
doing to the people the miners and
others in the energy business it's a
disgrace your time is up thank you it's
an absolute description
two minutes
well that was very interesting
um first of all
China is illegally dumping Steel in the
United States and Donald Trump is buying
it to build his buildings
putting steel workers in American Steel
plants out of business
that's something that I fought against
as a senator and that I would obviously
a trade prosecutor to make sure that we
don't but I have to urinate taking
advantage of by China on steel or
anything else
you know because it sounds like you're
in the business or you're aware of
people in the business you know that we
are now for the first time ever energy
independent we are not dependent upon
the Middle East but the Middle East
still controls a lot of the prices so
the price of oil has been way down and
that has had a damaging effect on a lot
of the oil companies right
we are however producing a lot of
natural gas which serves as a bridge
and I think that's an important
transition
we've got to remain energy independent
it gives us much more power and freedom
than to be worried about what goes on in
the Middle East we have enough worries
over there without having to worry about
that so I have a comprehensive energy
policy but it really does include
fighting climate change because I think
that is a serious problem
and I support moving toward more clean
renewable energy as quickly as we can uh
because I think we can be the 21st
century cares about energy power and
create millions of new jobs
but I also want to be sure that we don't
leave people behind that's why I'm the
only candidate from the very beginning
of this campaign who had a plan to help
us Revitalize coal country because those
coal miners and their fathers and their
grandfathers they dug that coal out a
lot of them lost their lives
turned the lights on and they powered
our factories I don't want to walk away
from them so we've got to do something
for them but the price of coal is down
worldwide so we have to look at this
comprehensively that's exactly what I
have proposed I hope you will go to
Hillary
we have entire policies one more
audience questions one more question and
it comes Crowder and at naked who do you
think has won so far for a wrap up yeah
good evening my question to both of you
is
regardless of the current rhetoric
would either of you name one positive
thing
that you respect in one another
Mr Trump would you like to go first
well I I certainly will because I think
that's a very fair and important
question look I respect his children
his children are incredibly able
and devoted and I think that says a lot
about Donald I don't agree with nearly
anything else he says or does but I do
and I think that is something that as a
mother and a grandmother is very
important to me
so
I believe that this election
has become in part so
um I'm out I need one more drink so
conflict oriented so intense because
there's a lot at stake
this is not an ordinary time and this is
not
an ordinary election
we are going to be choosing a president
to set policy for
not just four or eight years but because
of some of the important decisions we
have to make here at home and around the
world from the Supreme Court to energy
and so much else
and so there is a lot at stake it's one
of the most consequential elections that
we've had
and that's why I've tried to put forward
specific policies and plans trying to
get it off of the personal and put it on
to what it is I want to do as president
and that's why I hope people will check
on that for themselves so that they can
see that yes I've spent 30 years
actually maybe a little more working to
help kids and families and I want to
take all that experience to the White
House and do that every single day
Mr Trump
well I consider her statement about my
children to be a very nice compliment I
don't know if it was meant to be a
compliment but it is a grid I'm very
proud of my children the guy asked what
do you respect manager they've done a
wonderful job and they've been wonderful
wonderful kids so I consider that a
compliment I will say this about Hillary
she doesn't quit she doesn't give up I
respect that I tell it like it is
she's a fighter
I disagree with much of what she's
fighting for
I do disagree with her judgment in many
cases
but she does fight hard and she doesn't
quit and she doesn't give up and I
consider that to be a very good also
Could Happen by the
I want to thank both the uh the
candidates want to thank the the
university here this concludes the town
hall meeting or thanks to the candidates
the commission Washington University and
to everybody who watched please tune in
on October 19th for the final
presidential debate that will take place
Nevada Las Vegas good night everyone all
right debate wrap up it's like the
sequel that is
just never end relatively quickly you
were gone for what did you think what I
think let me check Twitter right now
while you're talking go ahead gosh what
did I think
um
it was so personal like 90 of it just so
personal it it didn't
I I don't imagine it'll move the the the
barometer much easier right now I don't
think it'll change much of anything I
think it was it was
a lot of fluff a lot of garbage keep
going a lot of personal attacks a lot of
personal trying to correct the uh
the score I don't know
if you could believe it was less meaty
than the left who won check the live
chat on YouTube because I'm checking the
Twitter
are you checking the live chat am I
checking the live chat I said check the
live chat I well the live chat is just
zooming by so fast it's hard
to make it out
all right never mind Trump one Trump one
Trump one I see a lot of Trumps but
Trump crushed
Trump crushed what is it Trump won
um but
it wasn't a decisive victory at all
changes nothing from Peter
Trump's best debate yet I think it was
less of it less of a train wreck as it
could have been considering this past
week this is the Trump we wanted to see
Trump wins by virtue of the fact that by
rights we shouldn't put him in the put
them in the ground tonight Trump was
much better than the first time hard to
tell pretty even since I came in late
Trump stepped up this time Trump you
both need to get faced in the last
debate Trump had this one Trump didn't
do what he needed to do
the general consensus seems to be
congrats it for we have 14 000 people
watching
yeah 14 600. that's silly yeah why are
you watching us go away could you
imagine a concert venue of 14 000 people
and I just disappeared to pee
that could be weird imagine in before
the poll were 8 or 15.
uh that was my interpretation I think if
you were to pick just on this debate
alone
probably about like 51.49 Trump yeah
yeah uh probably but not enough that he
needed after this last week and I also
think with a couple of his answers he
just cut an ad for her he had a couple
of answers that were really bad and all
she needs is one or two answers to keep
harping on that throughout the week you
kind of see with Mike Pence Mike Pence
had a huge victory in the debate night
but he said Donald Trump didn't say that
and all it took was one or two instances
where he was wrong
because Trump did say that and they just
ran with it and then it pretty much just
washed out another video these days he
didn't say that they have a rewind they
have a rewind real problem
I never thought they were gonna rewind I
didn't know okay if I had another one
and everyone would have said that so
what do I think tonight I think Trump
went in with the worst week ever in a
presidential campaign history uh and I
think he did okay
I think if this had been the first
debate and he had put in this kind of
performance in the second debate and
third debate maybe it would have helped
but his first debate was so bad if you
look at the consensus this one was
better I don't know if it was good
enough but then again Trump has been
marvelous at lowering expectations
honestly people just expect unless he
just went out there and said to grab him
by the tonight people would
consider it a victory so I I do think he
probably probably
exceeded the bar I don't think he he
went as hard on Bill Clinton's sexual
assault history
allegedly
uh as he should have he I don't think he
even mentioned the name Juanita
Broderick
once he was talking about the the
um girl Jones and you know he talked
about the woman who Hillary defended the
rapist the rapist and the the kid yeah
the 13 year old I think he never even
mentioned that name which I know he's uh
I don't think it was really good for him
to go after that you don't think so no I
really don't I don't think it was that
because I think what he just did was so
recent and the whole like she did her
husband's worse I don't think would work
and I think she was ready for it so I
actually think it's a good thing that he
didn't I think when he did it looked
like he was a little bit out of control
as far as temperament
he was pacing a lot he was looked almost
like he was hiding behind the chair I
know that sounds it sounds
sort of frivolous but it's not for
people watching again who are undecided
people who aren't engaged in the
political process that matters
um and I think Hillary seemed a little
bit more in control but she also seemed
a little bit more
um stale there are a few answers where
she just kind of just went off and just
filling time I think they both rambled a
lot more this time yeah a lot more I
don't think they answered the questions
a whole lot tonight and I think that's
because it was very personal tonight
a lot of it was just really really
personal your emails uh your taxes uh
your husband rapes uh you rape it was
which in some ways I think is a victory
for Trump because I think I was fearing
he was he he I didn't think he had the
capability to go there because I think
he's afraid to track uh to attack
Hillary on a personal level
because we know if he loses she can she
can buy harlemen Trump in uh in New York
to harm him in uh in in a lot of
different ways so in just four minutes
so in four minutes 730 740 votes 39 said
Trump won 31 said Hillary and 30 said
neutral now keep in context there that I
have about 282 000 followers most of
them will be pro-trump or certainly
anti-hillary so for the majority now
people will say 39 that drop only 31
said Hillary Trump needs a big victory
so the fact that the vast majority of
Voters either said Hillary or neutral
would be considered a loss for Trump
yeah you have to give a handicap a
little bit to Hillary there you have to
give handicapped Hillary again these are
people you'll call you people can say
I'm a cuck and they'll say oh you're
no listen my followers here
obviously are not Hillary fans if you
look at them and uh 38 said Trump but a
majority of them this is the problem
Donald Trump has never been close to 50
in a Republican primary and he's never
been anywhere I don't think he's been
above 42 percent in a general at any
point so keep that in mind don't lie to
yourself people are saying the polls are
rigged and he's going to win in a
landslide listen this anything can
happen it's anyone's game but there's
about an 80 chance that Hillary wins and
I don't think that tonight Trump did
enough now you need to Mark the people
who are telling you that the polls are
rigged and Trump will win in a landslide
and when that doesn't happen you need to
remember to not trust them because
they're lying to you and we're not lying
to you I think this was a pretty give
and take if I had to give it to someone
probably Trump just by a hair and I
don't think that was enough after grab
it by the I don't think that was
enough
on the
bright side I think it will change the
headlines a little bit tomorrow at least
people will be Beyond
in some ways you know the the
dropping that you know two days before
the the debate was it good because it's
a distraction gives some Trump something
has to defend against on the flip side
um it has a short life span because now
that tomorrow's the headlines will have
nothing to do with that it you know it
so I think he defended it somewhat well
what do you think uh do you think this
changes enough for the headlines
tomorrow
anyway just bearing that moving forward
something positive in this again because
the expectations for Trump have been so
low where they'll just say you know what
probably the headlines will probably
read he turned in a d of course you'll
go to huffpo and salon and it'll just
say he's done he's over I think the
other sites out there or people who are
trying to be fair-minded oh Kenneth bone
I can follow the Wall-E character oh
really look at this look at this later
he's on Twitter for people who can't see
look at this Everybody follow Kenneth
bone right now
there you go
there's a little victory for tonight
see Silver Lining
um
headlines tomorrow do you think a favor
I think it'll I think in neutral on
neutral-ish shows I think you'll see you
know Trump had a better performance
and I think that'll probably be the
takeaway hey Trump had a better
performance in the first debate and so
to your point I think that's probably
correct I think that would be awesome
because his stamina his stamina uh and I
think that for
I mean the polls came out before the
Friday event and she was ahead 12 in
Pennsylvania
um gosh his path to Victory is just
narrowing so he needs to win Florida
Ohio Pennsylvania and either New
Hampshire or Colorado and he needs to
hang on to states that are in a balance
like North Carolina Nevada Arizona
Georgia it's just mathematically very
unlikely that he wins I'm not going to
lie to you you want to be lied to turn
into one of the big sites who just tells
you Trump is god king and this isn't the
place for you I'm not going to lie to
you it's very unlikely that he wins and
not only unlikely in the general sense
but when you add up the electorate math
it's even less likely so I think he had
a better performance I think he did
pretty well if I were to give it to
someone I would give it to Trump do I
think it was enough probably not
especially when you take into account
that I think they've gotten more dirt on
him I think those tapes were just the
start of it
and I don't think this was enough for
someone like my wife probably not an
isolated incident no it wasn't an
isolated incident and even if they don't
have them ready right now people who
were producers from the the uh The
Apprentice have said there are far
there's far worse on the b-roll and they
are trying to get their hands on believe
me Clinton's have the connections
because of people like Donald Trump who
gave him so much money yeah they'll be
able to get their hands on it so I think
this is a very turbulent election I
think it's anybody's game
I think the first debate was a game
changer for Hillary I think they went in
about neck and neck was I think it was a
game changer for Hillary I think she had
a very good performance I think they
went in here with Trump behind
significantly and I don't think he did
well enough to make up that ground I
could be wrong I think to his to his
um to benefit him I think he at least
did not make it worse tonight he didn't
make it worse following
the last couple everyone was saying it
was do or die for him tonight I think he
did
um
much more poorly that it extends it to
the third debate which is what people
wanted they wanted to the final stanza
right now we're in the 15th round or for
mixed martial artists we're in the fifth
round on the scorecards that next debate
I think will be pivotal so I think it's
extensive what do you expect from the
next bait what do you think is going to
happen there
I think it looks more like the second
debate
more of the same kind of a wash I think
it looks more like the second debate
because I think he will see how and he's
he's a narcissist I think he'll see how
much more uh positive feedback he'd
received from this debate and I think
he's going to want to continue that so I
think that the rest of this campaign
won't be determined by the debates I
think it will be determined by what
happens between the debates and between
the last debates and election and I
think the clintons are the best ever in
the history of mankind between that last
debate between that last you have your
chance to put your cards in the table
both of you and then between that and
the election they know how to drop bombs
I've always been talking about this
so the next debate is it on the 19th
it is whatever next Wednesday is not not
this coming Wednesday but the Wednesday
after that so I think after that debate
correct you can wait for some serious
bombs 19th and so anyone who wants to
count their their their uh their tickets
before they hatch here do so at your own
Peril um I think this is going to be
drawn out and I think Trump needs some
serious
serious shots uh to win this I think he
needs to land a looping overhand right I
don't think this was enough and you can
tweet me at a Crowder you can tweet him
at night people are saying don't drive
home stay here don't crash home I would
not count on Wikileaks coming through
no I wouldn't count on Wikileaks either
I think that's that's a lot of Bluster
yeah I think it's a lot of just internet
news fluff I also I don't think
Wikileaks has a vested interest in Trump
winning I think a lot of the Trump
people are looking for a savior they
think it's going to be Julian Assange
and I don't think he's that guy I don't
think he likes Hillary but I don't think
he's pro-trump so I think if you're
looking for them to save you uh instead
of looking for them to save you and
getting complacent you should get a bit
uh get busy so there we go what's the
Telly you had three drinks one of them
was 11 so that's technically four and I
had four so technically five
um there you go that livestream debate
we will be here not only will we be here
for the next live stream we'll have
guests on that live stream yep Courtney
mcbrady Casey possibly Ben Shapiro oh
this week will event Shapiro and Kevin
McGinnis from what I understand and Nick
depalo plays hipster a hobo yep and then
um we will also be live streaming all of
election night you didn't know that but
now you do all of election night will be
live streaming the results and uh
hopefully keeping you from wanting to
swallow a sword I am
at s Crowder this is my producer at not
gay Jared who is not gay follow him on
Twitter or drunk I'm not drunk
I'm not drunk but he is homosexual
that's been our live stream good night
to you see you on Thursday live